in the DVD extras is a thing where
you're directing the film but this bit
where you're having to direct wolves
yeah I knew you were having to like
encourage the wool sit well yeah well
you know I tell you I remember when we
got these rules overrule Wilson I don't
know
here's you ever think of like salesmen
who like you know carpet with carpet
thing vacuum cleaner you always see them
and they come into your house and they
throw ashes and they sure like that and
they go like that and it and it cleans
it perfectly and then you you call your
friends over and you throw the same [ __ ]
and the floor and I stain is there and I
got the guy with the Wolves yeah he
showed me how they would behave you know
that he would push a button and the wolf
would come over here when I got out
there as well didn't you [ __ ] just like
that I was I was 10 days over scheduled
30 days into the movie and and I and and
they said well what are you gonna do I
said well I'm not gonna change the name
sake of the movie I got to figure out
how to send dogs you know this is
miniature money you make everything how
you make them you know and it's it's no
it's anglish that Betty what you have to
do apparently
what's that they like that belly being
rubbed that's true doesn't everyone
yeah yeah I'm a diva rules yes no no the
rules do I had girlfriend got me a
present to go with these wolves they
weren't time but they were socialized
and there were no that means they just
don't kill you yeah there was huge and
they like having their belly rub I'm
tickled a wolf's belly was it the belly
you were tickling I
um selling sort of toiletry products as
a rep up and down the country but you
never gave up the dream of being a pop
star but that you're in the new one
you're in the new store well it hardly I
mean I'm my voice is in it for a second
I recorded a little line in it something